[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und dunia
Hayali schönen guten Abend humanitäre
Waffenruhe das ist das was der
französische Präsident heute von Israel
gefordert hat damit geht macron in
seiner Wortwahl über das hinaus worauf
sich die EU Staats und Regierungschefs
gestern erst in ihrer gipfelerklärung
verständigt hatten da war und ist die
Rede von humanitären Korridoren und
Pausen für humanitäre Zwecke im
Gazastreifen für die einen mag es ein
verbaler für die anderen ein veritabler
Unterschied in der Formulierung sein
israel lehnt aber so oder so weiter jede
Forderung nach einem humanitären
Waffenstillstand ab unterdessen wurde
der Bodeneinsatz ausgeweitet Tim
Kröger Krieg am Himmel über Gaza seit
dii Wochen hält er die gesamte Region in
Atem und ein Ende ist nicht absehbar
laut israelische Militär gingen die
Bodenoperationen im Gazastreifen weiter
Einheiten sein erneut vorübergehend mit
Panzern und Luftunterstützung
einmarschiert am Abend dann die
Ankündigung als Folge der Angriffe der
vergangenen Tage werden die Bodentruppen
heute Abend ihre Aktivitäten ausweiten
das israelische Militär geht in allen
Dimensionen massiv vor um die Ziele des
Krieges zu
erreichen die humanitäre Lage im
Gazastreifen wird jetzt schon immer
schwieriger für die mehr als 2 Millionen
Menschen die hier auf engstem Raum
zusammenleben laut internationalem Roten
Kreuz haben es heute immerhin weitere
hilfslastwagen und ein Ärzteteam
hineingeschafft das un-hilfswerk für
Palästina warnt dennoch vor einem
Zusammenbruch der öffentlichen Ordnung
es fehle an fast
[Musik]
allem Krankenhäuser Schulen
un-einrichtungen wo tausende nach
Sicherheit suchen müssen respektiert
werden das israelische Militär aber
wirft der Hamas vor unter anderem
Krankenhäuser als Schutzschilde zu
benutzen in der größten Klinik im
Gazastreifen dem Schifer Krankenhaus
bewege sich die Hamas frei betreibe
kommandozellen was die Hamas aber
bestreitet von hier aus befehlen sie
Raketenangriffe und führen hamaskräfte
die Terroristen operieren im und unter
dem schiferkrankenhaus und in anderen in
Gaza vernetzt durch
Tunnel in Tel Aviv wurden die Menschen
heute mehrfach von Luftalarm
aufgeschreckt noch immer schießt die
Hamas ihrerseits Raketen auf Israel ab
ein Geschoss schlug in einem Wohnhaus
ein vier Menschen wurden dabei verletzt
die Nachbarn
schockiert wir sind 1949 eingewandert
ich habe alle Kriege erlebt sowas habe
ich noch nicht gesehen das ist sehr
erschreckend wir fühlen uns unsicher in
einer Stadt die die sicherste der Welt
sein
sollte und wie jeden Tag erinnern sie
auch heute Nachmittag kurz vor dem
Beginn des Schabbats an die Geiseln
symbolisch bleiben die Plätze der
Menschen leer die von der Hamas nach
Gaza verschleppt wurden
fragen wir nach bei Michael beverunge
auch heute für uns in Tel Aviv Michael
wir haben es gerade gesehen und gehört
der Bodeneinsatz wurde also ausgeweitet
heißt es jetzt offiziell ist das eine
neue Taktik oder was steckt
dahinter ja auch hier herrscht
Rätselraten ist das der heimliche Beginn
der Bodenoffensive oder nicht klar es es
ist keine Kommandoaktion wie den letzten
Tagen sie hat relativ früh begonnen es
wird von großen panz kolonn berichtet äh
trotzdem ist unklar was mit dieser
Aktion bezweckt wird sie ist ja auch
regelrecht angekündigt worden wir haben
es im Beitrag gehört vom amprecher
hagari es kann Taktik sein um den Gegner
zu verwirren es kann auch eine neue
Strategie sein mit vielen kleinen
Stichen quasi eine Bodenoffensive die
einfach nur so nicht genannt wird
vorzubereiten eines ist jedenfalls klar
nach Zurückhaltung sieht das nicht aus
und Israel weitet seine Operationen am
Boden von Gaza aus und gehen denn da
jetzt Militär und Politik Hand in Hand
also ist das alles
abgestimmt na ja davon ist auszugehen
wenn das so angekündigt wird
und auch so durchgezogen wird dass die
Politik dahinter steht also
einzeloperation oder eine verborgene
Strategie der Armeeführung gibt es nicht
es gibt zwar viele Berichte darüber dass
Armee und politische Führung sehr über
Kreuz gelegen haben in den letzten Tagen
und natürlich ist immer noch die
geiselfrage unklar was bedeutet das
jetzt wenn eine Bodenoffensive
vielleicht näher rückt für die Geiseln
aber die Strategie davon kann man
ausgehen ist mit Sicherheit zwischen
Armeeführung und Politik abgestimmt sagt
Michael bwerunge live aus t Aviv vielen
Dank die UN Generalversammlung hat heute
eine weitere Sondersitzung zum
israelisch-palästinensischen Konflikt
aufgenommen und über einen von Jordanien
vorgelegten
Resolutionsentwurf abgestimmt Jordanien
hatte diesen im Auftrag der
Palästinenser eingebracht fragen wir
nach und zwar bei shakunal La benanergy
in Berlin und Claudia Bates in
Washington beginnen wir dort Claudia
worum geht's in dieser
Resolution ja die Resolution wurde mit
deutlicher Mehrheit verabschiedet gerade
eben aber ohne die Stimmen z.B der USA
und mit mit einer Enthaltung
Deutschlands in der Resolution steht
vieles worauf sich im Prinzip alle
einigen können sie hebt stark ab auf den
Schutz von Zivilisten und auf humanitäre
Hilfe für die Menschen in Gaza und
soweit wäre das wohl unstrittig gewesen
aber letztlich konnten sich die
arabischen und die westlichen Staaten
nicht darauf einigen welche Seite
eigentlich verantwortlich gemacht wird
für den Krieg und daneben gibt es
einiges was die engen Partner Israels
nicht mittragen konnten so wird z.B eine
human militäre Waffenruhe gefordert das
ist schon abgemildert zunächst sollte es
Waffenstillstand heißen und eine
Waffenruhe wollen die USA nicht
mittragen sie sind für humanitäre Pausen
ja es ist auch nicht so dass die USA
Israel blind unterstützen gerade hatte
Präsident Biden noch die Angriffe von
israelischen Siedlern auf Palästinenser
verurteilt und gesagt sie würden Öl ins
Feuer gießen und das müsse aufhören aber
die USA unterstützen nach den
Terrorangriffen der Hamas das Recht
Israels auf Selbstverteidigung und davon
ist in der Resolution eben keine Rede es
gab einen kanadischen Zusatz zu dieser
Resolution der auch von Deutschland
unterstützt wurde indem die Hamas klar
verurteilt wird und die Freilassung der
Geiseln gefordert wird aber dieser
Zusatz hat gerade eben keine Mehrheit
bekommen und das noch die Resolution
kommt nicht aus dem UN Sicherheitsrat
sondern aus der Vollversammlung und ist
damit völkerrechtlich nicht bindend dann
gehen wir direkt rüber nach Berlin zu
shakunala banerj shakunala die
Resolution stellt also jetzt jetzt klar
dass der Krieg durch die Angriffe der
Hamas der Terrororganisation am 7
Oktober ausgelöst worden sind und auch
das Wort Terror kommt darin vor
Deutschland wir haben es gerade schon
von Claudia gehört enthält sich dennoch
warum ja es war offensichtlich einfach
nicht genug Außenministerin annaalena
berbock hat gleich nach der Abstimmung
eine Erklärung schriftlich abgegeben in
der sie ganz klar drei Punkte benennt
die zu einer zu einer Zustimmung gefehlt
haben und zwar sagt sie zum einen der
Herr masterterror ist nicht deutlich
genug benannt worden und nicht klar
genug beim Namen genannt worden die
Freilassung aller Geiseln sei nicht
deutlich genug gefordert worden und wie
wir es gerade schon gehört haben das
Selbstverteidigungsrecht Israels ist
nicht bekräftigt worden in dieser
Resolution alles drei Punkte denen
Deutschland nicht zustimmen kann weil es
eben unverbrüchlich an der Seite Israels
steht wie die Bundesregierung auch
mehrfach bekräftigt hat und das sind
eben die drei äh die drei Punkte die
eindeutig gefehlt haben in der erklär
heißt es auch man habe noch bis zum
Schluss einige Verbesserungen in die
Resolution hineinverhandelt aber es hat
eben am Ende nicht gereicht dann
vielleicht noch ganz kurz nachgefragt
also eine Enthaltung dürfte dennoch
wahrscheinlich eine Art Affront für
Israel sein Stichwort staatsresort steht
Deutschland denn mehr oder weniger
alleine da ganz alleine nicht die
Erklärung betont auch dass viele
europäische Partner sich auch dafür
entschlossen haben dieser
dieser Resolution nicht zuzustimmen also
eine Einzelstimme ist es nicht aber es
ist auch nicht die gesamte Europäische
Union die sich da zusammengeschlossen
hat da setzt sich also die Zerrissenheit
die wir gestern beim EU-Gipfel gesehen
haben schon fort und Deutschland hat
auch eine besondere Rolle also Israel
schaut darauf wie sich Deutschland
positioniert und aus israelischer Sicht
kann eine Enthaltung wahrgenommen werden
als Rückschritt bei der
unverbrüchlichen Unterstützung dazu gibt
es auch einen eine Erklärung von
Annalena berbock die noch einmal betont
hat und ich ztiere ja einmal es ist ein
zentraler Bestandteil der Sicherheit
Israels dass wir das Leid der
PalästinenserInnen und Palästinenser
sehen deshalb setzen wir uns ohne
Unterlass für eine Verbesserung der
humanitären Lage der Menschen in Gaza
ein das bedeutet eben Nein zu sagen zu
dieser Resolution hätte geheißen dass
man diese Unterstützung für die
humanitäre Lage äh verweigert hätte da
ist man dann nicht mehr in einer
Position in der man auch vermitteln kann
und das scheint der Bundesregierung im
Moment auch wichtig zu sein ein
Vermittlerrolle einnehmen zu können die
wäre aufgegeben worden hätte sie nein
gesagt zu der Resolution und auch um das
noch mal klar zu sagen die Resolution
ist nicht binden spricht de facto
passiert jetzt nichts aber in diesen
Tagen des Krieges hat alles auch eine
nicht zu unterschätzende Symbolkraft
vielen Dank nach Washington und Berlin
für eure
Einschätzung die humanitäre Lage wurde
gerade schon angesprochen die Lage im
Gaza Streifen war aber schon vor dem
jetzigen Krieg ziemlich schlecht 80% der
Mens sollen auf internationale Hilfe
angewiesen gewesen sein 45% der Menschen
arbeitslos Arbeit gab es für einige in
Israel und im Westjordanland doch das
ist nun vorbei die Grenzen sind ja
bekanntlich gesperrt und auch für 100000
Palästinenser aus dem Westjordanland hat
der Krieg alles verändert denn auch für
sie ist der Weg nach Israel versperrt
Alisa jung über die unterschiedlichen
Folgen der geschlossenen Grenzen diese
Sperranlagen trennen Israel und das
Westjordanland fast 200.000
Palästinenser passieren sie
normalerweise sie arbeiten in Israel
doch jetzt ist die Grenze zu seit dem 7
oktober kommt fast kein Palästinenser
mehr rüber wer Arbeit in Israel hatte
steht jetzt ohne Job
da das wird sicher Auswirkungen auf
unsere Wirtschaft haben ich habe keine
Beschäftigung
mehr ich fahre die Arbeiter die nach
Israel
W sie kein haben wie soll ich da
arbeiten an diesen Jobs hängen Familien
Kinder ihre
Zukunft diese Situation betrifft mich
sehr sehr
sehr meine Frau ist schwanger und ich
habe Angst keine Sicherheit was soll ich
machen wenn das Kind zur Welt
kommt sie haben schon Kinder i konnte
als Anstreicher in Israel viel mehr
verdienen ob und wann die Grenze wieder
für alle aufgeht das fragen sich Zeus
Menschen aus dem Westjordanland und auch
rund 18000 Menschen aus Gaza durften
zuvor legal in Israel arbeiten nun
wurden sie im Westjordanland wie hier in
ramala festgesetzt ihre Erlaubnis
entzogen aus Angst wie es nun weitergeht
will abuohamm dass wir sein Gesicht
nicht
zeigen alle dies Arbeiter haben nichts
zu tun mit dem was passiert ist das Leid
der Arbeiter ist sehr groß hier sind so
viele Menschen hier wurde uns geholfen
aber das ist kein Platz um zu bleiben er
braucht das Geld will unbedingt wieder
in Israel
arbeiten die Menschen können kaum
überleben gebe es nicht die
internationale Hilfe würde das ganze
Volk verloren
gehen das Arbeitsministerium hilft mit
einem Notfallprogramm hofft aber dass
Israel die Arbeitskräfte mindestens
genauso
braucht schon lange verdienen viele ihr
Geld auf dem israelischen
Markt und auch die israelische
Wirtschaft wird leiden wenn die
Palästinenser nicht dort
arbeiten doch israel fürchtet um die
eigene Sicherheit so dürfen die Männer
hier nicht raus wir wollen nur dass Sie
uns zu unseren Familien nach Gaza
zurückbringen damit wir sie sehen bevor
sie sterben sie sterben dort und wir
sind hier wir wollen unsere Familien
Kinder und Frauen unklar ob und wann sie
sie
wiedersehen und wir machen erstmal
weiter mit Nachrichten und mit dir
Gundula das US-Militär hat Luftangriffe
auf zwei Orte im Osten Syriens geflogen
Ziel sein von iranischen
Revolutionsgarden genutzte Stützpunkte
gewesen sagte usverteidigungsminister
Austin es handele sich um
Selbstverteidigung und sei eine Reaktion
auf Angriffe auf usstitkräfte im Irak
und in Syrien in der Region attackierten
pro-iranische Milizen seit 10 Tagen US
Militärstützpunkte trotz des derzeitigen
Fokus auf den Nahen Osten hält die EU an
ihrer Unterstützung für die Ukraine fest
das erklärte Bundeskanzler Scholz zum
Abschluss des EU-Gipfels in Brüssel die
Staats- und Regierungschefs sagten Kiev
anhaltende Waffen und
munitionslieferungen vor dem zweiten
Kriegswinter zu zuud dem Plan die EU
weitere Milliarden Hilfen Kritik daran
kam von Ungarn und der Slowakei die sich
dann aber doch der gipfelerklärung
anschlossen Deutschland hat der Ukraine
ein drittes Flugabwehrsystem vom Typ
Iris geliefert das Luftabwehrsystem sei
ein weiterer wichtiger Beitrag zum
Schutz der Zivilbevölkerung der
kritischen Infrastruktur und der
Soldaten heißt es aus dem
Verteidigungsministerium die russische
Armee setzt ihre Angriffe im Osten der
der Ukraine fort in der Region Charkiv
wurde eine Feuerwache getroffen acht
Einsatzkräfte wurden
verletzt vor der ersten Tarifrunde
zwischen der Deutschen Bahn und der
lockführergewerkschaft GDL zeichnet sich
bereits ein Arbeitskampf ab wegen der
Aussicht der Bahn unerfüllbar hohen
Lohnforderungen der GDL hat Bahnvorstand
Seiler schon jetzt eine Art
Schlichtungsgespräch vorgeschlagen mit
einer Friedenspflicht also ohne Streiks
das wies gdlchef weselski bereits scharf
zurück das Hinzuziehen von Dritten sei
eine
Eskalationsstufe und im Tarifkonflikt
des Einzel und Großhandels dauern die
Verhandlungen nun seit Monaten an mit
der Forderung nach einem verbesserten
Angebot der Arbeitgeber rief die
Gewerkschaft werdi erneut zu
bundesweiten Warnstreiks auf 10tausende
gingen auf die Straßen werdi und die
Arbeitgeber liegen noch weit auseinander
letztere verweisen auf die angespannte
Wirtschaftslage kommende Woche gehen die
Verhandlungen
weiter wie kann man unerlaubte Einreisen
in das Bundesgebiet stoppen populistisch
gefordert und sehr schnell formuliert
ist ja der Satz Grenzen zu das
Schengenabkommen und damit der freie
Binnenmarkt die when mehr oder weniger
passe insbesondere aus wirtschaftlicher
Sicht wäre so eine Entscheidung also
komplett unsinnig etwas anderes und auf
den ersten Blick sinnvoller erscheint
das was gerade tatsächlich ja auch
passiert verschärfte Kontrollen an und
auch um die Grenzen herum aber wie sieht
diese Maßnahme auf den zweiten Blick aus
Connie schemens und Jan Frederik Fischer
waren mit der Bundespolizei unterwegs
und zwar an diversen rein heute morgen
die Beamten im Einsatz an einem der
wichtigsten Grenzübergänge Deutschlands
das Ziel illegale Einreisen verhindern
und das lukrative Geschäft der Schleuser
durchkreuzen selten waren
antiflüchtlingsmaßnahmen so spürbar
Polizeikontrolle Ausweis mehr als 12000
illegale Einreisen stellten die Beamten
bereits in diesem Jahr fest schon jetzt
mehr als
2022 doch Migranten an der
deutschschweizerischen Grenze einfach
zurückschicken das ist auch an
stationären Kontrollen nicht einfach so
möglich wenn jemand keine gültigen
Papiere für die Einreise nach
Deutschland hat wird er in die
bearbeitungsstraße mitgenommen und je
nachdem ob die Person dann Asyl gern
äußert dann zur
landeserstaufnahmeinrichtung nach
Freiburg weitergeleitet kurz zuvor das
Team der Bundespolizei kontrolliert ein
ICE noch bevor dieser deutschen Boden
erreicht ein Sonderabkommen mit der
Schweiz macht's möglich diesmal treffen
sie auf einen jungen Mann aus Marokko er
hat kein gültiges Visum für ihn endet
die Fahrt hier die Beamten nehmen ihn
mit prüfen seine Daten und verhindern
fürs erste die Einreise und Pass die
Person wird dann den Schweizer Behörden
übergeben und die Schweizer machen das
dann in ihrer eigenen Zuständigkeit
weiter doch das heißt auch viele
versuchen es an einem der anderen 44
Grenzübergänge einfach erneut
Deutschland für viele ein langersehntes
Ziel und die Schweiz guckt nicht immer
so genau hin auch an den Übergängen zu
Polen und Tschechien wurden Maßnahmen
verstärkt auch hier sind Feste
Grenzkontrollen nun rund um die Uhr
möglich doch das bindet viele Beamte und
Schleuser nutzen Alternativrouten
sinnvolle Asylpolitik sieht anders aus
kritisier Experten und fordern
stattdessen mehr Konsequenz bei
Abschiebungen wir bräuchten dringend
funktionärende migrationsabkommen wo ab
einem Stichtag Menschen zurückgeschickt
werden können in
Herkunftsländer wie den Irak in
Transitstaaten wie die Türkei und wir
bräuchten sichere
drittstaatsregelungen Grenzkontrollen
also nur Symbolpolitik nein erwidert
badenwürttenbergs Innenminister und
pläert doch auch für ein
Maßnahmenbündel es gibt nicht den einen
Knopf den man drückt und die Migration
ist erledigt die Intensivierung des
Grenzschutzes ist ein wichtiger
Mosaikstein das reicht aber nicht aus
wir brauchen zwingend auch eine
Absenkung der sehr hohen sozialen
Leistungen insbesondere für Flüchtlinge
die sich illegal bei uns aufhalten und
zum dritten Flüchtlinge aus Ländern mit
sehr niedrigen
anerkennungsquoten müssen in einem
schnellen Verfahren bearbeitet werden
und so bleiben die festen Kontrollen an
den Grenzen als eines von vielen Mitteln
mindestens noch bis Mitte November
Verlängerung
möglich und mit Nachrichten unter
anderem aus der Wirtschaft geht es jetzt
auch bei dir weiter grundula an der
Börse bleibt Siemens Energy zu diesem
Wochenschluss das Thema die Aktie hatte
stark verloren weil bekannt wurde dass
das
Unternehmen dass das Unternehmen mit der
Bundesregierung über Unterstützung in
Milliardenhöhe verhandelt Valerie Haller
an der Börse zunächst warum hat Siemens
Energy Bürgschaften beantragt ja weil
Siemens Energy Probleme hat Garantien
von den Banken zu bekommen die aber
braucht das Unternehmen wenn es seine
Großaufträge abarbeiten möchte die
Banken zögern weil Siemens Energy
massive Probleme mit seiner
windkrafttochter Gamesa hat und deswegen
mit Milliarden Verlusten kämpft das
macht sich nicht gut bei den Geldhäusern
deswegen soll jetzt der Staat
einspringen für den Bund dürfte das
Risiko überschaubar sein schließlich
geht es um Garantien nicht um direkte
Zahlungen die Bundesregierung will sich
zu den Details nicht äußern sagt aber
dass Siemens Energy relevant sei für die
Energiewende abgesehen davon beschäftigt
das Unternehmen über 90.000 Menschen zur
Aktie der Ausverkauf ist erstmal
gestoppt wie steht es um die Siemens
Tochter die Aktie hat sich tatsächlich
heute etwas erholt nachdem sie gestern
zwischenzeitlich fast 40% verloren hatte
schon eine Hausnummer für ein DAX
Konzern zur Wahrheit gehört aber auch
dass Siemens Energy Aktien schon länger
stark unter Druck stehen großer Knick
Ende Juni als die Probleme im
windturbinengeschäft ein unerwartetes
Ausmaß Annahmen seitdem hat Siemens
Energy 68% an Börsenwert verloren unklar
ist ob sich die Siemens AG an der
Rettung beteiligen wird immerhin ist der
Technologiekonzern noch mit rund 25% an
Siemens Energy beteiligt nicht ige sehen
Siemens da in der Pflicht vielen Dank
Valerie für alle Informationen nach
Frankfurt der frühere chinesische
Ministerpräsident Li keang ist im Alter
von 68 Jahren in Shanghai gestorben an
den Folgen eines
Herzinfarkts der
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler war bis März
10 Jahre lang Ministerpräsident er galt
als moderat und hatte sich immer wieder
für Reformen und die Öffnung Chinas
ausgesprochen Lee gehörte nicht zum
Lager der engen Vertrauten von Präsident
Schi und wurde von diesem zunehmend ins
Abseits
gedrängt das Freitagsspiel der
Fußballbundesliga haben am Abend die
beiden Tabellen letzten der VfL Bochum
und Mainz 05 bestritten die Partie steht
in den letzten Sekunden und demnach
gewinnt wohl Bochum
2:1 und die deutsche
Frauennationalmannschaft feiert an
diesem Abend einen glücklichen 5 Z1 Sieg
gegen Wales im dritten Gruppenspiel der
nations League für interimst Trainer
Horst rubesch wieder ein gelungenes
Debüt Lea Schüller von Bayern München
traf in Sinsheim gleich zweimal und auch
Julia gwiinn nutzte ihre Chance mit
Blick auf eine Teilnahme an Olympia 24
in Paris braucht die Mannschaft am
Dienstag wieder einen Sieg dann gegen
Island
es gibt ja so Momente die vergisst man
nicht die bleiben für ewig auch weil sie
zu einer kollektiven Gänsehaut geführt
haben so wie dieser hier Schäfer na
innen geflang Kopfball abgewehrt aus dem
Hintergrund m
Schießen mit dem ersten WM-Titel
schreibt am 4 juli 1954 nicht nur
Deutschland Fußballgeschichte sondern
auch Reporter Herbert Zimmer die Kraft
inklusive Anziehungskraft die das Radio
oder besser gesagt der Rundfunk
entfalten kann ist dann doch einfach
eine sehr besondere am Sonntag wird der
alte Kasten der mit der Zeit mitgegangen
ist 100 Jahre jung christard lepple mit
einer omage an das erste elektronische
Massenmedium morgens um 5 Uhr rüttelt
Selin ka ihr junges Publikum aus den
Federn ihre morningsh bei Radio Fritz in
potzam ist werktags bis 10 Uhr on air
Radio heute im Zeitalter von Netflix und
tiktok hört das noch jemand ich weiß die
Meinung hält sich stark Radio wird
aussterben hier Spotify KI auch großes
Thema ne ich glaube dass vor allem und
das merke ich jeden Tag die Menschen
wollen auch echte Menschen seit 100
Jahren gibt's was auf die Uhren das
Radio vom Luxusgut für wenige zum NS
propagandrument
vom lightmedium der Aufbaujahre zum gute
Laune Begleitmedium nach wie vor hören
zwei Drittel der Deutschen insgesamt 400
verschiedene radiprogramme das
Erfolgsrezept Radio ist das einzige
Medium wo das Bild im Kopf entsteht
achtung Achtung hier ist Berlin im
wxhaus auf Welle 400 m 29 oktober
1923 nach der Ansage um 20 Uhr das erste
Live shellow
Konzert die Lizenz zum Hören kostet
anfangs für jeden 25 Milliarden reismark
Rundfunkgebühr in Deutschland herrscht
Inflation hören ist Luxus und nur mit
Kopfhörer möglich Radio war zu diesem
Zeitpunkt das einzige echtzeitmedium das
war die einzige Quelle wo ich in im
Augenblick eine Nachricht hören konnte
oder einem Programm folgen konnte aus
bescheidenen Anfängen mit ein paar
Zuhörern steigt das Radio rasant
weltweit zum populärsten Medium auf
Einstein prophezeit unter 30 dem Radio
eine demokratische Zukunft nur dre Jahre
später lässt Hitler alle Radiostationen
gleichschalten im neuen Volksempfänger
göppelschnauze genannt wird bis zum
Untergang 45 Unterhaltung und Propaganda
gesendet Neuanfang nach
1945 in den Wirtschaftswunderjahren
erlebt das Radio seine Blütezeit beim
Frühstück im Auto bei der Arbeit mit
Schallplatten Rauchen im Studio und
coolen Sprüchen Plattenaufleger der die
Hit fix Mix bis in die späten 70er sind
Moderatoren Popstars jennif Rush
Destiny Thomas Gottschalk Günther Jauch
Hanne Lore Fischer auch Oliver Welke
machen mit ihren morningshs Karriere die
Münchner Radi Legende Fritz Egner hat
Generation von Rockfans begleitet
welches Ständchen
er zum
hundersten natürlich würde ich
vorschlagen
satisfaction ich bin nie ganz zufrieden
und doch immer wieder happy vor dem
Mikrofon zu sitzen also doch die Stones
doch die Stones ach wie schön das Radio
lebt na dann alles Gute für die nächsten
Jahre auch von uns hier stehen zwei
Radio Junkies mit Radio ist man einfach
weniger allein ja oder schön
genau um 0:20 Uhr freut sich Laura
barnik wenn Sie Ihr in unserem heute
journal Update folgen und uns sehen Sie
dann hier morgen wieder machen sie es
gut wo auch immer sie sind
[Musik]
tschüss herzlich willkommen zum Wetter
der her Monat Oktober war bisher nass
und mild und was die Temperaturen
betrifft setzen der Sonntag und der
Montag noch mal eine Schippe drauf und
zwar im Süden des Landes in Rosenheim im
Oberbayern da erreichen wir am Montag
Temperaturen an die 20° der Grund dafür
ist der südfö der südliche Wind steigt
an den Alpen auf und fällt auf der
anderen Seite trocken und warm wieder
hinunter im Normalbereich lägen wir bei
Temperaturen um die 10° und da sehen wir
auch im Norden des Landes in Hamburg z.B
kommen wir noch am Esten an diesen
Normalbereich ran hier fällt auch diese
wärmespitze nicht so deutlich auf aber
im auf aber immerhin erreichen wir am
Sonntag hier auch um die 15° und ab
Mittwoch da gehen auch die ersten
Novembertage dann noch im zweistelligen
Bereich also relativ mild weiter wir
kommen aber jetzt zum Wetter von heute
Nacht im Nordosten setzt sich da das
eine Regengebiet fest von Südwesten
folgt aber schon wieder das nächste am
ersten trocken bleibt es im Südosten die
Temperaturen sinken auf 10° an nieder
und oberreihen und auf 4° an den Alpen
morgen ist es am kühlsten auf Rügen mit
9° im Breisgau können bis zu 17°
erreicht werden und wie eben der gesamte
Monat Oktober wird es auch morgen ein
nasser Tag im Norden bleibt es dazu
Dauergrau bei einem nur auf der seebögen
östlichen Wind ansonsten lebt der
südwestliche Wind auf mit stürmischen
böhnen in den Berglagen und es gibt
immer mal wieder auch regenlücken und
Wolkenlücken nur südlich der Donau da
bleibt es trocken und da setzt sich auch
längere Zeit mal die Sonne durch und
genau hier erreichen wir dann auch am
Sonntag und am Montag die Werte um 20°
sonst kommt von Westen aber immer wieder
schauerartig verstärkt der Regen auf am
Dienstag endet der Oktober grau und
verregnet und damit tschüss